[Music]
on this thursday night russian hackers
blamed for new malicious attacks on
canada
the us and the uk why research into a
covid19 vaccine
is the target i think that's pretty
appalling i have to say plus how a judge
says canada's own spy agency
broke the law ottawa's strategy to
restart the economy we've outlined
seven priority areas the 19 billion
dollars being doled out
a reality check on the risk of air
travel
why one infectious disease expert says
what happens on the ground
is more worrisome and letters of love
almost like having jim back with her
back with me
messages she wrote to her husband
recovered decades later
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
the race to develop a vaccine for the
novel coronavirus was already intense
now there's a new sinister layer canada
the u.s and the uk
warned that russian hackers possibly
linked to russian intelligence
are targeting organizations involving
the research and development of a
vaccine
including here in canada microlay looks
at the threat
and what's at risk in our top story
tonight
the race to develop a vaccine for
covid19 just got political
alerts from canadian uk and u.s cyber
security agencies aren't just warning of
hackers trying to steal medical research
they say the hackers almost certainly
operate as part of russian intelligence
services
this is a global issue they are
every actor in the world is looking for
the vaccine
a report in april had warned of attacks
against a canadian biopharmaceutical
company
but the attribution then was the very
generic cyber threat actor
with this attack canadian and uk
officials seem determined
to publicly shame russia and i think
that's pretty appalling i have to say
at a time where the world's coming
together we're all trying to find a
vaccine that both our people and
people around the world can benefit from
to have the russian government engaged
in that
endeavor i think is needs calling out
and i think the world should know it
russia has vehemently denied all
involvement through its state-run media
channel saying the allegations weren't
backed up by proper evidence
but cyber experts say that's not true in
this case the
russian hacking group apt-29 or cozy
bear
was identified through code it had used
before a sort of signature
it's the same group that was accused of
trying to influence the 2016 u.s
presidential election
with the current attack it's unclear if
any information had been stolen
and security officials didn't speak to
motive so
they may have been trying to get
intellectual property to either
benefit their own research to piggyback
on canadian
and western efforts they may also have
just simply wanted to disrupt
vaccine development in canada knowing
that this would have
some kind of effect russia has been put
on notice
and the hackers now know they're being
watched but if they're as good as
they've proven themselves to be
they probably knew that before mike
turley global news toronto
a scathing court decision was made
public today about illegal tactics
canada's spy agency
csis has admitted it used in national
security investigations
federal court justice patrick gleason
says csis has a cavalier institutional
approach to the rule of law and is
calling
for a comprehensive review of the agency
the judge says cesas used illegally
collected intelligence to obtain
warrants for counterterrorism
investigations that included
paying an individual known to be
facilitating or
carrying out terrorism during an
investigation into canadian foreign
fighters and ceases knew it was illegal
gleason says the review must look at the
interactions between csis and the
federal justice department to fully
identify systemic
governance and cultural shortcomings and
failures
he says anything less will fall short of
ensuring confidence and trust in the spy
service
the federal ministers responsible for
security and justice said today
they've asked the national intelligence
watchdog to look into the judge's
findings
and they were asked if anyone will lose
their job or be disciplined
over this breach as we've indicated
this this was an evolving and complex
area of law
and and and in my experience and and
in my review of all of the circumstances
leading up to this decision
i believe that at all times people were
acting in good faith
and in an effort to fulfill their
responsibilities to uphold the rule of
law
the head of ceases was asked if he
expects to continue to lead the spy
agency
the activities that we have undertaken
have done been the guys of
protecting canadians from the threats of
terrorism
in this specific case we have said that
you know we have carried out these
activities
with the protection of the crown
immunity when it
became clear in january 2019 that this
the crown immunity was not
uh available protection anymore for
these activities i immediately ordered
that we
seized these activities this court
ruling was issued in late may but was
confidential what's been released now is
heavily redacted to remove references to
specific
warrant applications four years ago the
federal court found cesius illegally
kept potentially revealing electronic
data about people who posed
no security threat and breached its duty
to inform the court
of that data collection program from our
context on this i'm joined by christian
luprecht he's professor in leadership in
the department of political science at
the royal military
college professor the justice who
delivered this ruling says it's
difficult to overstate how disturbing
these circumstances are
what in simple terms was cesis doing to
break the law at times knowing it was
breaking the law
yeah the decision suggests that there's
serious reputational risk and that's
what we also get from the reaction from
the government and from
ceases so ceases obtains warrants under
uh
a lower threshold than what is required
for criminal prosecution
uh something known as reasonable
suspicion and so
ceases clearly believed that it was
meeting its obligations under the letter
of the law
but it appears that the judge deemed
that both the letter of
the law was not adhered to and the
spirit of the law and that was also the
essence of the 2016
decision uh that the public expectations
and legal expectations have clearly
evolved substantially beyond
where ceases itself is at at the time
caesars was under considerable
pressure with regards to national and
international transnational terrorism
and to end it acted
expeditiously and made judgment calls on
the spirit of the law that were clearly
not in line with legal expectations as
interpreted by the federal court
well the head of ceases said today it
works in a complex geopolitical
environment and relies on human
sources and sometimes it has to pay them
what is the danger if that goes
unchecked
so we we have a circumstance now where i
think the risk of this recurring is
unlikely we have an intelligence
commissioner that signs off on
and reviews warrants we have the
national security intelligence
review agency that this government has
put in place and we have the national
intelligence and security committee of
parliamentarians
that can also look at these issues and
so there might be a public perception
that ceases or some of its agents
have gone rogue but this was never the
case and i think this is also what the
director the court
and the minister affirmed here rather
this is a matter of process and a matter
of substance
of how ceases deals with its business
is the line between what's legal and
illegal in intelligence gathering and
spying a fine one
uh it is certainly a matter of context
um but that context and the legal
precedent for that is evolving
rapidly with the number of court
decisions that we have
and often given the changing thread
environment uh the operational
dimensions of the organization evolve
faster than the ability
uh to either challenge the operations in
court or to have appropriate review
mechanisms in place to be able to
comment
on those operations and so clearly this
is an instant where operations
got too far ahead of the ability to keep
track of the grounds on which ceases
was making its operational decisions the
justice calls for a comprehensive review
of css what do you think has to change
uh well certainly as i have mentioned
there are now
three institutional entities in place
that were not in place at the time when
this type of conduct
was happening and the government is
taking this so serious that we have
the court gave the government a heads up
and we have a
coordinated response between both ceases
as well as the justice ministers and the
minister of
public safety so this suggests that
there is broad agreement with regards to
the decision
as well as the way forward but the
government is clearly so concerned that
it has appointed a former supreme court
justice to monitor implementation of
this decision
to report back to the bureaucratic
oversight
entity that it's to say in syria and for
that entity to report to
niskop which is composed of
parliamentarians so that canadians have
assurance and accountability on csis's
efforts to change its ways all right
professor lupray thank you for your time
it's been my pleasure thank you now to
the pandemic the prime minister justin
trudeau has announced a 19 billion
dollar deal
to help the provinces and territories
restart their economies
safely and prepare for a potential
second wave
the money will cover the next six to
eight months there are
seven priority areas including testing
and contact tracing
personal protective equipment and
long-term care
the prime minister says the aim is to
get things back on track
safely we also have to make sure that
people can get to work safely
that children are looked after and that
those who can't find work right away
are supported so making sure there are
enough
safe child care spaces available or
supporting people who don't have paid
sick leave
those must be top priorities too
the deal has been under negotiation for
weeks the provinces and territories have
agreed to spend the money on what it's
designated for and the prime minister
confirmed today the canada u.s border
will stay closed to non-essential travel
until august 21st
only essential workers trade shipments
and those reuniting with immediate
family members
are allowed to cross there are more
developments tonight regarding the
liberal government
and the we charity the house of commons
finance committee has
opened its investigation into this into
the issue the
ethics commissioner says he will now
investigate whether the finance minister
bill morneau
and the prime minister violated conflict
of interest rules
abigail beeman joins me abigail we're
learning that the we charities stood to
be paid much more money than was
originally reported what came out of the
minister's testimony today
well donna the minister of diversity
inclusion and youth bartis
chagger told the committee that had the
program taken off and expanded
we stood to be paid 43.53 million
dollars
the previous number made public was 19.5
million dollars with which chagger
explained was an initial amount all part
of the
912 million dollar program and checkers
stressed the majority of that money
would go to student grants things got
heated with questions from the
opposition
the ndp's charlie angus pushed chagar as
to whether she had discussed
the prime minister's connections to the
we charity
yes these questions were posed our focus
was on delivering a program
for students to be able to volunteer
provide service opportunities in
communities
and linked them with not-for-profits
that were looking for much-needed
supports
and therefore that was my focus yes i
asked tough questions of the public
service
when we made this decision and the
public service recommended that it was
the only organization that would be
the senior bureaucrat who initially
called we told the committee she did so
on april 19th
letting them know broadly what the
government would be looking for in a
potential partner
rachel wernick says then on april 22
after the prime minister's public
announcement
craig kielberger emailed her a detailed
proposal unsolicited
wernick confirmed there was never a
competitive process citing the very
short
time frame to deliver the very large
program
abigail we've heard lots of apologies
from the prime minister and the finance
minister today the deputy prime minister
added another one
what did she say well christopher
freeland said
everyone in cabinet bears responsibility
for the whole
we affair and she offered a very clear
apology
i very much regret what has happened
and i'd like to say to canadians i'm
really sorry
we have so many huge issues facing
our country clearly our government made
a mistake
two committees are now investigating
this issue abigail plus the ethics
commissioner and today we learned that
he is going to broaden his investigation
that's right mario dion will also be
investigating finance minister bill
morneau
something the ndp and conservatives were
calling for more no declined in
interview requests but said in a
statement that he will
fully cooperate with the ethics
commissioner and also reiterated his
apology saying he should have recused
himself from discussions involving we
as his daughter works for the
organization now we still don't know
whether committee will hear from the
prime minister trudeau said again today
his office is still looking
at the invitation donna all right
abigail beamon in ottawa thank you
the wii charity has announced a major
overhaul
it says it is cancelling its flagship we
day activities for the foreseeable
future and returning to its roots what
it says is international development
work
focused on children and families says
it's hiring a risk and compliance
officer who will report to the board of
directors and
creating more separation between its
not-for-profit branch
we charity and its for-profit enterprise
me to we the chairs of both the canadian
and u.s board of directors resigned in
the spring
many board members have been replaced
and staff have been laid off
during the pandemic major new clues in
the quebec manhunt coming up why police
believe martin carpontier
is still alive
an update tonight on the search for a
quebec father suspected of killing his
children
marta carpontier has been on the run for
nine days now
his six and eleven-year-old daughters
were found dead on saturday and
there's been no sign of their father
since though police say they believe
he is alive and on the move mike
armstrong is in the
town of saint apollinaire tonight mike
well donna police have been tight-lipped
for a couple of days now well there was
a
major update here at the command center
this morning
quebec police gave a short statement but
for the first time
saying there has been a sign mate
carpentier is alive
according to provincial police they have
recovered evidence that cho capacity
spent time
in a trailer in this area and they
believe there were items
taken that would help him survive now
police are asking anyone in the area to
check their sheds cottages
trailers or hunt camps for any signs of
entry
and anything that may be missing they're
even asking that if anyone has
hunting or wildlife cameras that they
check whether cac ponce might have set
those off
now this has been a day and night effort
but it may be in the wrong place
police say the evidence they found means
capacity is mobile
and could be outside the area they've
been searching
and it is a massive area this is a
transport canada plane that's been part
of the search it's been using
thermal imaging to scan the ground back
and forth
earlier this week police said they were
concentrating on 15 square kilometers
well this plane overnight searched an
area bigger than 400 square kilometers
now even with capacity still on the run
plans are underway to bury his daughters
it's being scheduled for this coming
monday in levi quebec
their hometown donna
all right mike armstrong thank you
what's waiting in the wings ahead one
expert weighs in on the safety of air
travel
during the pandemic
as canadians make plans for summer
vacations thousands are getting on
planes
though the federal government is still
recommending against non-essential
travel
as heather eurex west explains as more
people fly there are reports of possible
exposure
to covid19 on dozens of flights
during what should be the height of the
summer travel season
canada's busiest airport is eerily quiet
air travel has taken a massive hit
because of the pandemic
but there are still thousands of people
flying into and across the country
some bringing the virus with them the
canadian government has flagged at least
31 flights so far this month for
possible covet 19 exposure
17 of those were international flights
according to the canada border service
agency
the number of international passengers
arriving at canadian airports each week
has tripled since early may between june
29th and july 12
roughly 91 300 travelers entered canada
by
air the good news is because of cabin
air filtration systems and policies
requiring people wear masks
the virus doesn't seem to spread easily
on the flights themselves
i think at the end of the day if the
question is can you get kobit 19 on an
airplane
the answer is yes of course you can but
i think the risk
is much smaller than what people think
it's what happens after passengers land
that's more of a concern
it's why anyone entering the country is
required to quarantine for 14 days
though air canada would like to see
those rules relaxed
there are a bunch of options out there
and i think it's important to have that
discussion and see what would make
sense among those options allowing more
travel with countries with low
rates of transmission but this
infectious disease specialist
says that option comes with risk we've
also seen countries
that have done a good job of getting the
curve flat
and then they've had flare-ups it's why
ottawa says air travel rules will remain
in place
for now preventing international travel
on
is a continued thing we need to do
because even with restrictions
health officials are seeing how easily
kovid 19
can take flight heather urex west global
news
calgary darling discovery next tracking
the mystery of these long lost love
letters
they say love is something you can't put
a price on so what do you do if you find
a stack of long lost
love letters that don't belong to you it
happened to a saskatchewan couple who
discovered hundreds of handwritten love
letters while renovating their home
brian kessler explains how the real life
love story
unfolds this was the gift from my friend
this leather case is full of history
that wynn richards thought
ended up in the trash thankfully she was
mistaken
love is the greatest problem isn't it
really in june a saskatchewan couple was
renovating their basement when some
insulation tumbled to the ground in the
pile was the case filled with hundreds
of letters
so of course i got curious started
reading and
opening up a few and you could just
smell these letters were
like old antique they were sent from
lashburn saskatchewan to leeds
england following the second world war
the messages beginning with to my very
own darling i was like we have to find
the owner
to these or at least some family members
using the names and addresses as clues
noella mitsuwing turned to
social media hoping to find the family
and with some luck she tracked down the
author's love
now 96 years old much like having jim
back with her back with me
yeah but together with my memory
with his lesson wynn was a city girl in
the british royal air force
j.a richards or jim was a flying officer
the son of a saskatchewan farmer
we just looked at each other
and he said i'm going to marry that girl
and i i never told my kids that
he proposed within months but victory in
europe meant jim's return to canada
that's when the letter started back and
forth every few days
for a year and a half until they could
finally reunite
what did you feel in that moment
wynn bought her wedding dress as soon as
she arrived in canada and said i do in a
lashburn church
during their 54 years together they
raised three children
i think that's what this world needs
is love what everybody say
jim died in 2001. wynn never remarried
she knew there would never be another
man like her husband or another love
story she'd rather be a part of
ryan kessler global news saskatoon
so sweet and that is global national for
this thursday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is this team of
ducks in a montreal park or
it could be a raft of ducks or a
paddling two or or a flock
depending we'd love to see your canada
please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
bye bye